you're making it spicy no fresh spices
we got a team swap which button
whoopsie whoops ow why did I do that
clearly I don't know what I'm doing we
got 30 minutes left
[Music]
hey y'all so this week we are in
Charleston South Carolina I'm on my way
to the Charleston Wine and Food Festival
an annual celebration of Charleston's
culinary excellence
but first let's make a quick stop at the
McIntosh to pick up chef Jeremiah bacon
in the 2017 rav4 hello chef Jeremiah hey
girl what's goin on man how are you
how's everything everything's going
great nice to finally meet you good to
have you in trust it's gonna be you
other two we're gonna have a great time
yes we are you ready yes sir all right
let's do this
so tell me a little bit about yourself I
actually grew up here in Charleston grew
up on John's Island which is about 15
miles from here spent ten years in New
York City and Boston and Martha's
Vineyard can you tell us a little bit
about a Macintosh it's opened about five
years ago and I would called sort of
American tavern upscale Bistro we print
the menu every day so it gives us a lot
of wiggle room with some of the farmers
coming in and it's been a lot of fun
what are the couple's going to be
cooking today all right so we're doing a
little quail we've got a couple
different things that they can be doing
on the stovetop so a little bit of
grilling a little bit of sauteing a
little bit of flight poaching a little
bit of chop chop knife work I think
they're gonna have fun
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hello Charleston my name is Karl Monroe
and I'm your host welcome to tasty date
night today we're here at the Charleston
Wine & Food Festival to watch as two
couples put their relationship and
culinary skills to the ultimate test in
a cooking showdown whoever impresses our
judge the most can look forward to a
romantic date night out at the Macintosh
our first couple have been together for
over 20 years please help me welcome
Michelle and Fred cook Daley and Rachel
is a great taste tester we are so
excited about today this is just
something that we have dreamed about
being able to work together because we
are very competitive to have a night out
for ourselves at a beauty is a week
we're serving others we're hosting
others and this will be just an icing on
the cake all right our second couple
have only been together for a year and a
half please help me welcome Landon and
Ryland we cook a lot at home probably
like four to five times a week I like to
cook the one pot dishes like Indian food
pasta homemade pasta got to make it
ourselves I like to dice things I
usually cut my fingers light is good at
cooking me I'd say the grill master
yeah he's the grill master it'd just be
so nice for us to like be able to go out
we're pretty confident that we're gonna
win I mean I say it's oh we're gonna win
we're definitely gonna win so our chef
and judge for today please help me
welcome
Charleston's own chef Jeremiah bacon
so Jeremiah what are a couple is going
to be cooking today we're gonna be
grilling quail lacinato kale turnips
pearl onions
baby carrots ooh let's see if that looks
as good as it sounds
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right couples you have 30 minutes to
cook and plate this dish without further
ado let's put 30 minutes on the clock
please and let's get tasty all right so
Fred I'm going to go ahead and get the
turnips okay yeah perfect so I forgot
what we're doing you're gonna get the
marinade going yes the sharp knife sharp
sharp sharp are we cooking snail whale
whale whale am i hogging all the space
you are I'm sorry I'm not moving fast
enough look at Rochelle over there Fred
and Rochelle they seem like a power
couple Fred looks like he knows how to
cook some stuff so it is gonna be hard
to beat him hey Rochelle hey how you
doing over there
just hop in Landon and Ryland are our
competition but there are also great
people there's a girl they are so we
have to put our friendship aside and go
for it
I mean this isn't like a competition is
it
what should the couple's be cooking
first the turnip puree was probably the
first thing you want to get on let's say
get that peeled cut and in the pan I
think they're in good shape and you may
take over you start talking great you
know peelers are like my worst nightmare
Oh getting turned up on turn up my make
a mess you're good perfect perfect I'd
be a good sous chef does he got you
calling him chef chef Fred yes yes you
can call me that too yes yeah I'm making
a mess this is exactly what it looks
like at our house Garhwal all this
together or do I roll yes this is a lot
more stressful than I thought it was
gonna be huh huh at an angle oh yes okay
I handled the quail
I'm his sous chef so whatever he told me
to do with these carrots and this kale I
just did it that's what a great job am I
making them pretty enough ha ha I feel
so good I'm concerned about them being
pretty you know one thing too cutting
everything sort of the same size so it's
same kind of cooking time it's important
jaw
which one is it don't turn mine off what
to do that you did a great job you guys
come here often babe her carats looking
way better let's see huh I thought so
yeah oh I was are we switching teams
yeah Hey what the lid on what would you
do
friendly competition at its finest all
right y'all we have about 20 minutes
left 20 minutes left
feels like it's been an hour how do you
soft in this yeah yes stop I don't know
nothing about this classic tip for
perfect grill marks is 10 o'clock and 2
o'clock they'll have the perfect marks
on there oh did you cut yourself we knew
he would be the one that would hurt
himself looks like tiny little birds is
it better to do like poor little quails
hey Rochelle and Fred how is it going
we're freaking out what we're moving
well looks great from my end are you
doing Fred supersaturated with
exuberance yeah all right I'll let y'all
get to it
all right landing and Rylan how are you
two doing personally um I'm about to
burn this quail oh look at that oh it
looks some very tasty
fancy stuff right here that is some
fancy stuff great team work here I did
the quail try to do a real pretty like
crisscross action on it and give it a
nice like char I am worried about this
what Jim in a warning oh that looks good
well look how romantic it is you hear
the church bells yes Houston over
looking good ship free and let's see yes
yes yeah when it comes to the quail what
is the preferred temperature that it
should be cooked at we like to cook
about medium medium plus we like some
red and some pink in there have enough
better y'all that was my Paula Deen
butter Rowling has a butter tattoo
that's how much
oh well I can't show you France tattoo
you almost caught my rag oh [ __ ] I swear
I can cook alright we have five minute
warning five minutes
how's that look that's pretty good that
was just like the video I worked on to
turn up your a all right come on Top
Chef what there's gonna be a quail
sitting on it you won't be able to see
it right right right
sure sure just spicing it up look spicy
spicy all right couples this is a
30-second warning Oh hurry I'm hurrying
oh my goodness let's see the plate okay
oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god
oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god
ten nine eight seven six five four three
two one time time now turn to your
partner and give them a hug that was so
intense yes I love it give the other
couples a hug - I know you want - oh my
goodness this has been incredible it's
been a lot of fun we're excited when it
was time to start plating who's like oh
my god are you serious I'm elated I'm
glad it's over I almost burned the place
down like twice we'll see how it goes so
let's bring out our first couple of
Rochelle and Fred please show us what
you got
[Applause]
and looks beautiful that looks great
lacquer looks good all the colors look
great I just want to make sure I get
every single thing in seasons good nice
presentation I thought the dish turned
out great thank you
we put love and care in our dish in only
30 minutes and we're the winners even if
we don't win we're still going to have
any quail in my teeth nope
all right let's go ahead and bring out
our second couple Landon and Ryland
let's see what you got
what's great nice presentation nice
color is very nice grill marks on there
thank you follow the ten o'clock two
o'clock right there mm-hmm
how was a how was the time constraints
on that was it feel challenging I'll
know I blocked out as soon as we started
yeah all right chef let's go ahead and
cut this quail well that's great
nice color on the onions yeah how's the
puree it was good yeah yeah I think the
season was good it was really delicious
was very beautifully presented I will
say cool very nice thank you yet fan yes
I would say I'm about like a six or
seven maybe and probably about a three
three I mean I think we did better than
that you know it tastes good let's go
ahead and talk about Rachelle and Fred
it was great to see them work together
it was very obvious that they had been
together for 20 years they did a great
job that worked as a team that worked
clean they had focus cuts were good
thoughtful movements Landon and Ryland
two different approaches definitely two
different styles it was you know
organized chaos but when it came down to
it they finished and they were a great
team they're seasoning was a little bit
more focused the puree was a little bit
smoother after tasting both dishes do
you think that we can come to a decision
on a winner
I do
all right chef Jeremiah bacon can you
please let everyone know how we came to
our final decision it was tough it came
down to just a few small details but
there were important details both teams
did an excellent job both approaches
were different but they came out with
great ending dishes but there can only
be one winner the winner of tasty date
night Charleston is Landon and Rylan
[Applause]
date night I'm surprised um obviously
I'm shocked
you know I think the salt Bay helped a
little bit there was a lot of chaos in
the kitchen things burning my hand
burning pots melting the chaos ended up
working in the end I mean that's kind of
like our relationship baby what is that
good
oh it's a little Bob but we had a great
time this experience and doing this
together having this time together
this was a date in itself yes we had a
brownie enjoyed it and met some good
friends yes yeah congratulations to both
of our amazing couples thank you so much
to chef Jeremiah bacon and the Macintosh
and my amazing audience this has been
tasty date night brought to you by
Toyota
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]